hey this is presh talwalker
we have a number point zero seven zero
zero seven zero zero zero seven zero
zero zero zero seven and so on
the decimal number shown has an
increasing number of zeros followed by
seven
first there's one zero and then a seven
then there's two zeros and then a seven
then there's three zeros and then a
seven then there are four zeros and then
a seven and so on
what is the one thousandth digit after
the decimal point
I think Rahul for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
so let's analyze the position of the
sevens in the decimal
let's say we have n representing the
number of seven that's appearing and
then a n is the position of it
so the first seven appears in the spot
number two
the second appearance of seven is in
spot number five
then the third appearance of seven if we
count carefully will be in spot number
nine
the fourth appearance of seven will be
in spot number fourteen
so we have a pattern here and we want to
figure out what a n is equal to
but we first have a recurrence
relationship
A2 is equal to A1 plus three
a three is equal to A2 plus four a four
is equal to a three plus five each time
we're adding one more than the previous
so let's work out the general case
we have a two is equal to a one plus
three which we can rewrite as A1 plus
two plus one
A3 is equal to A2 plus 4 which we can
rewrite as A2 plus three plus one
then A4 is equal to eight three plus
five which we can rewrite as A3 plus
four plus one
so continuing this pattern a n is equal
to a n minus 1 plus n plus one
so let's Analyze This formula
we have a n is equal to a n minus 1 plus
n plus one which we can apply the
formula using a n minus 1. so a n minus
1 is equal to a n minus 2 plus n we can
substitute this into the formula so that
a n is equal to a n minus 2 plus n plus
n plus one but why stop there we can
apply the formula to a n minus 2. a n
minus 2 is equal to a n minus 3 plus n
minus 1.
so then a n is equal to a n minus 3 plus
n minus 1 plus n plus n Plus 1.
we can continue this formula all the way
until A1 which is equal to two so a n is
equal to two plus three plus so on all
the way up to n plus one and now we can
use a famous formula we know that the
sum of the numbers from 1 to n is equal
to n multiplied by n plus one all over
two we need the sum to go up to n plus
one so we'll increase this then we need
to subtract 1 because we're starting at
two so a n is equal to n plus 1
multiplied by n plus two all over 2
minus one
now this is the position of the sevens
in the decimal expansion so we just need
to figure out if this is equal to one
thousand for an integer value of n
so we set this equation to n plus 1
multiplied by n plus 2 all over 2 is
equal to one thousand and one we
multiply both sides by two
so now we have n plus 1 multiplied by n
plus two is equal to 2002 this means we
have approximately n plus 1 squared is
equal to 2002 we take the square root of
both sides so n plus 1 is approximately
equal to 44.7 so let's test out some
values around this
so a43 is equal to 44 multiplied by 45
divided by 2 minus 1 that equals 989
then a44 is equal to 45 multiplied by 46
divided by 2 minus 1 and that's equal to
1034.
so we see that the 1000 digit is not
equal to seven and that means the one
thousandth digit is equal to zero and
that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign
[Music]